Let's think about the characters.
These five girls.
Where would they be in ten years, in a «SKAM 2»?
In ten years.
What's happened?
Sana has become a professional
basketball player.
And she's made it into the Guinness book
of world records for ...
... peeling carrots the fastest.
And ...
Yes, she's spent ten years practising.
And she's also managed to ...
... convince Yousef to believe in God.
So they can get married.
And then ...
Yousef wants a soccer team ...
While Sana wants a basketball team ...
Which would mean six and twelve kids ...
So they found a golden mean ...
So they'll have nine kids.
They'll have nine kids?!
Yes.
That's nice to hear, congratulations!
Nine kids before the age of 30 is pretty decent!
Yes!  Or, they're at least getting there.
And then you've got Chris.
She's just packed all her stuff and moved to Gran Canaria, where she lives.
And then there's ...
Noora.
She's engaged to William.
Yes. It's really cool.
They ended up together in the end, then?
Yes. They did.
But they're just engaged?
Yes ...
They could've married?
They're a bit back and forth, you know.
Yes. And then there's Eva.
Who has a child with Jonas.
Yes. They ended up together as well.
That's nice to hear!
And what about Vilde?
And Vilde ...
She ...
– Her and Magnus ...
... are a bit on and off.
Still?
Still.
But I think they'll be on and off forever ...
– But they'll end up together in the end.